So we're trying to find where 8.94 falls on this distribution. So it looks likes
it's about here, so this z score is going to be really high. For this one the z
score falls about here, which looks like it's still kind of in the center of the
sampling distribution, so now if we calculate the actual z score... We'll do
8.94 minus the population mean, which is also the mean of sample means. And then
divide by this standard deviation of the sampling distribution. Now to keep
things more precise, instead of using the rounded standard error, I'm going to
put this in my calculator. It's okay if you used the rounded error. You should
have still gotten it right. So if we do it like this, we get about 10.06. Which
is pretty big. And here if we calculate z-score. We'll say 8.35 minus the mean
of the sampling distribution. Divided by the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution. So we get about 0.92. We're going to call this zees of en, zees of
l. So now what's next?